[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
bah
m
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gestuelle espérant aboutir au sérieux
que je donne un micro
[Musique]
à
je suis
[Musique]
à
oui
c
[Musique]
à
vous
[Musique]
il veut
el materi retour
m
non
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
oui
voilà
qui sont construits sur six
à
[Musique]
tout
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
ça va
es12
un peu
schiste
higgins
[Musique]
non
vous
[Musique]
non
là
[Musique]
amazon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
ce combat
com
[Musique]
à
si
[Musique]
je suis
parti j'ai si souvent
[Musique]
si
on estime
gilbert
[Musique]
pour moi
il
oui
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
tous
à
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nicolas
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un deuxième
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
j'y vais pour recel
[Musique]
je pars en commentaire
nous quoi
nous plaît
[Applaudissements]
non
super
jusqu'à mo
[Musique]
us steel a dit à quelques journalistes
us au pis si
on pouvait lui accorde
traite les problèmes
j'ai fait qu'il ait
basculé
quand il s'agit de venir le parti
n'était décédé ce type et tonnelles
parfois quand il ya des hommes de la
migration
il a dit harper seven
mais pour l'essentiel
dans les biberons
pour les jeunes remontaient des
quartiers par les violences policières
la chute est sans nouvelles près de 300
organisations
sur tous les territoires qu'ils ont su
capable pour
que les sportifs
qui n'est pas de ce côté là
tirez pas l'accord avec les copines or
qui va lutter contre le racisme et pour
la solidarité
il n'y a pas un seul journal qui on
parle
cette couleur
les commenter cette manifestation
un hommage
suivi blé
on va faire une minute de silence
nos frères et soeurs
non
au méditerranée
dans la supérette et connor
de plus en plus en tentant de traverser
la manche
sur les routes des migrations
dans nos rives
au passage des frontières dans les alpes
dans les trains pour passer les pyrénées
dans les rues de nos villes
mimi défiance
pour tout l'édifice des violences
policières
dans nos quartiers
dans les prisons
une minute de silence
pour tous ceux et celles qui sont
intéressés dans nos rues en raison de la
couleur de peau ou à raison de la
religion supposée
une minute de silence
parce qu'après
ce sera un collège sera la lutte
unie de deux séances persie
merci à vous
on a commencé par une scène plus de
paroles et les faits au nom des 300
tonnes 40 organisations signataires de
cet appel pour une campagne qui va durer
pendant des semaines et des mois ce
n'est que le début
il s'appelle youssef alaoui
il est sans papiers il y un an il a
traversé tout le pays en marche en
avaient contre sans papiers de marseille
jusqu'à paris tandis que d'autres
sans-papiers partait de mon colis de
grenoble de strasbourg de lille pendant
des semaines grâce à la solidarité dans
chaque village enchanté pour arriver à
paris hays banque était aussi un hommage
jeudi 7 octobre
où on était soit sans fil ce jour là
encore pas de journée se jouerait encore
le méprise macro qui a refusé de
recevoir les marcheurs et marcheuses
du crb où il va parler au nom de
l'ensemble de ceux et celles qui vont se
lever ces prochains mois à 88
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde
merci d'être là merci de venir
aujourd'hui dire non à six et de combat
ce racisme institutionnel par l'état
aujourd'hui nous sommes réunis pour
combattre toute forme de racisme
aujourd'hui nous sommes plus 10 pour
l'avenir pour la liberté pour l'égalité
des droits pour la dignité et bien sûr
pour la solidarité
la solidarité c'est notre arme efficace
contre le racisme
le débat politique
de nos jours il est totalement dévorant
au défavorable aux étrangers avec ou
sans papiers
cette répression que l'état exerce
contre les étrangers doit cesser
la france a toujours été une terre
d'accueil
un pays de droits de l'homme
un pays de l'est de liberté de croyance
mais malheureusement aujourd'hui on voit
la mémorisation des esprits qui vis de
changer la devise de la république
le but de cette campagne
quand j'ai dit et de dénoncer toute
forme de raciste dans l'islamophobie
la négrophobie le racisme anti-asiatique
l'antisémitisme l'antitsiganisme
nous exigeons aujourd'hui la fin des
contrôles au faciès
la fin des violences et crimes policiers
la suppression des lois déprécie et
comptera 10 3 contre les sans-papiers
et la fermeture des centres de rétention
la n va changer de camp
nou revue on les suit mentalisation
défendent à des fins racistes
nous revendiquons l'égalité des droits
pour toutes et tous
l'accès réel à la santé à l'éducation à
des revenus décents
et l'accès au logement à toutes et tous
nous exigeons aussi la liberté et le
respect des croyances de chaque personne
et la régularisation bien sûr de tous
les sans papiers sur le sol français
sans condition et sans exception
aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale
des migrants
c'est notre journée il faut pas oublier
que nous sommes tous des enfants
d'immigrés
c'est les débuts de dudu campagne qui va
durer des mois qui va continuer dans
chaque ville chaque village chaque coin
dans les quatre points de la france
merci beaucoup et que la lutte continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la police
[Applaudissements]
la dignité
[Musique]
de
[Applaudissements]
notre pays va mal
notre monde s'appelle
produira
combien précieux troisième génération
nous sommes tous des enfants d'immigrés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais le visuel grossièretés relations
unissant disent les enfants d'immigrés
première monsieur ressources génération
nous tous présents passé huit heures
c'est mieux monsieur mon ancienne
génération
nous tous
c'est mieux
monsieur troisième génération mise en
fiche très discret
monsieur
génération nous
réunir monsieur brochet génération 90 où
les enfants imitent les premiers que je
troisième génération nous sommes tous
azimuts le premier touché troisième
génération du même coup une affabilité
première deuxième troisième génération
[Musique]
de geeks les première deuxième troisième
génération
nous sommes tous d'accord oui des vieux
monsieur troisième génération nous à
bout
de
leur action du coup
j'ai mieux deuxième troisième génération
nous sommes tous des enfants d'immigrés
très mieux 2e 3e génération prend corps
on veut celle où j'ai bien deuxième
troisième génération
nous ferons le composent immigrés très
bien deuxième troisième génération
nous sommes tous les ans comme il est
très bien deuxième troisième génération
nous sommes limités j'aime mieux
deuxième gros yeux
sachant tout
ce sont
des sujets
humains
par des principes
arrêtés
sans papiers
[Musique]
j'ai arrêté de me
mettais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des
[Musique]
travaux
épris d'amour dure et de sans-papiers
musée de morlaix les yeux voudrait
rappelle open libérer les immigrés à
retaper prince libérer les immigrés à
plus de libérer les sans papiers
[Applaudissements]
plus vous
libériez
libérer les immigrés et
les réfugiés
libérés les clichés
et les sans papiers
kubel et les sentiers
ivg les sans-papiers
libérer les sans-papiers
libéré sans papiers
vivent et des sans papiers
qui met les sans papiers
il est vrai les immigrés
bush et
qui devait les réfugiés
vivent et l'inde a touché
les 100 premiers
libérés le souk aux pieds
10 m et les sans papiers
il aurait laissé papier
et les puciers
libérer les sans-papiers
révéler les réfugiés
et les sans papiers a
libéré les son côté
dit démêler ce papier mais libéré les
sans papiers
divers et les appliquer
les sans papiers
du délai les sans-papiers
gibel et les sans papiers
les sans papiers
la main
donaire livré frontières teulet donnait
au
clair venez
tous les risques frontières de l'air de
l'air
de l'air de l'air aux bleus pointer de
l'est bel air pour le concert de l'air
de l'air
de leur plaire
il contient bonheur de leurs
occupants soeur de l'un d'eux les
auteurs
venaient
[Musique]
me lève pour la troisième de leur donner
de l'air
on
veut le protéger leur donneur ou
[Musique]
combler
[Applaudissements]
mon billet guerre du papier
pour avoir les papiers
pour avoir les papiers monnaies pour
avoir les papiers
pour avoir les pieds soit ils sont nés
pour avoir les papiers faut-il monnaies
pour avoir les papiers
pour un mois les papiers
[Musique]
pour être heureux les
pompiers disent chiche travail festif ce
sens c'est ça l'égalité des droits
ils nourrissent
pistis c'est ça c'est ça l'égalité des
droits pour tous mariés pour
éviter d'être
à leur écoute et l'état persil ou bien
les dernières s'il vous plaît
ivan nova
régularisation et
régularisation
[Musique]
de tous les jours
les avancées
dans la
régularisation
[Musique]
des
immigrés
ne
sauriez que
la
régularisation de tous les sans papiers
de guy l'horizon et tous les immigrés
[Applaudissements]
appartient pas les immigrés
changer
régularisation des coûts les attaques et
il arrive un jour
de là
[Musique]
allez
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les simples
tous
[Musique]
les immigrés
il faut souffler
on va bien
rooney sans papiers
les immigrés ça
g
[Musique]
les
immigrés
50e il faut changer ce statut va changer
suivre son jeu
[Musique]
me grey
g
et
[Musique]
lisa sion
vous irez
[Musique]
il dit
tous les autres
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
compass
autant
[Musique]
beaucoup
tous
[Musique]
à
là
[Musique]
moi
le
[Musique]
là
et
[Musique]
salut
l'idée
[Musique]
jouanno
lui
[Musique]
thomas
oui
[Musique]
g
solidarité
[Musique]
tous les cas
ribéry t il au pape les
solidarités
solidarité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
solidarité
quartier d'affaires sont une grille de
la chaîne de rythme même pas mal
solidarité mais laissons pas de
solidarité
[Musique]
la commission solidarité
damas
seuil 10
[Musique]
solidarité
non
et
solidarité
solin
[Musique]
solidarité
c'est une arrivée
[Musique]
m
gary d
solidarité
et
tu
l'idée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut
prêté
il sait
seul
[Musique]
moi je
le salut
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va bien
[Musique]
m
salut
et vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une
m
il
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
blanc soleil
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
owen
[Applaudissements]
ne
oh
le
je 2
e
qui
ils sont conscients et
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
mais quoi
oui
non
[Musique]
et
il
non
m
[Musique]
il
arrive à sion la rentrée
tha
[Musique]
c'est
fait
au pire
[Applaudissements]
les ans
les
[Musique]
il
à
[Musique]
m
et
oui
[Musique]
désolé
m
[Musique]
et
non mais
[Musique]
à
temps
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour tous
m
[Musique]
ce
[Applaudissements]
car
[Musique]
à
par son père
il
le
ok
[Musique]
tous
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sénateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
pourquoi
il
à
[Musique]
bon
quoi
[Musique]
non
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
on
cela
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
non
[Musique]
nous
non
[Musique]
oh
m
ça
[Musique]
bon
les perturber
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour m
m
le mot
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
ap
[Musique]
le haut
oh
je sais
[Musique]
le bon
m
[Musique]
non
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
non
aïe
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il avait même
[Musique]
bien
m
[Musique]
vim
je
non
[Musique]
mais
robin aubert
[Musique]
ce combat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
assez noir
le
la gestion des
le mieux
[Musique]
attention
hamon
[Musique]
marin
à
on
[Musique]
jacques
sapiac
attention
la perception
[Musique]
tab à 2
attention
[Musique]
dutil
il
maliki
meetic
[Musique]
il pas
je
[Musique]
c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
me côté
bon
mercredi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marc a cette fois ci fait onze ans que
non non non ont ce pouvoir qui font du
bien on sent mieux
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi il vaut la vie
[Musique]
la
beauté
[Musique]
pourquoi
à ce pouvoir
aux sentiers
bord
[Musique]
pour
tous bords
[Musique]
à ses pouvoirs du
président
[Musique]
m
pourquoi
[Musique]
preppy j'ai
assez pour
ainsi le pouvoir
[Musique]
pour
les immigrés l'enclos
pouvoir
c'est pourquoi
au seul premier
à s'émouvoir
de ce papier
j'ai pu voir qu'il peut dans leur
possible et
on se moquait
de nous voir
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi
aux sans papiers
[Musique]
solidarité avec les sans-papiers
solidarité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
solidarité avec les sans-papiers
solidarité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
solidarité
solidarité avec les autres viennent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas les immigrés c'est vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
la raison
bush et son
[Musique]
m
avec les autres
[Musique]
le jeu sur
en
solidarité avec les réfugiés sont
solidarité
c'est pas les
[Musique]
immigrés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces deux
éteignez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à gérer
fin juillet
[Musique]
monsieur
c
[Musique]
et
di natale ont tout est à nous rien
n'était
et pour la guerre aux sans papiers tout
est à nous tout est un mot qui voit la
guerre
civile
tout est au
doute être
la gueule
[Musique]
m
lugano
ivo la guerre
[Musique]
tout est à nous toute atteinte aux
dépens lager aux sans papiers ou des
panneaux tout est à nous et tant la
guerre aux
immigrés
tout est un auteur de 13 buts et à
nouveau la guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous voyez même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
inquiétant le policier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ap
le policier
[Musique]
c'est le patron
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
papier
[Applaudissements]
m seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette
proposition
reconnu par les policiers
[Musique]
justice
c
m
[Applaudissements]
mais bon
[Musique]
simon
[Applaudissements]
j'aime isolé
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et puis
[Musique]
oui
oh
c'est
l'eau
[Musique]
il
ne sont pas là
fragile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par là
car tient sa mère
[Musique]
quartier sa mère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette équipe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
le papier
[Applaudissements]
les importations
régularisation
des
[Musique]
jeux suis je
suis je reste à paris je suis je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
ceux ci
elle
dailymotion a récemment dit moulin
sans papiers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant
hypothèse et galina
jaca
m
[Applaudissements]
il
ap
arrivé
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
ouais
m
à loger
[Applaudissements]
je
il
g
féret
[Applaudissements]
iv
m
ouais
le
mais où
écoutez à plus de 26 plein entre la
prise et
[Musique]
paradis on rappelle gilles ouaki de
service s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
bonjour je parle au nom de l'association
sur dix sur dix milite pour
l'assainissement des relations
franco-africaines
aujourd'hui nous prenons la parole pour
dénoncer le système de la françafrique
le néo colonialisme français et ses
conséquences sur les migrants et les
immigrés de france la france artix un
enlisement militaire dans les pays de la
région ce l occupation militaire
coopération militaire et policière la
région sahélienne est souvent l'occasion
d'expérimenter le matériel et les
techniques de répression forcé sur les
africains et qui seront plus tard
utilisés dans les quartiers populaires
et aux frontières du territoire de
l'hexagone de la colonisation a
aujourd'hui la france emploie structurer
les armes et les collines des régimes
autoritaires africains en les formant
ici en france au nom d'une prétendue
guerre comprimé au rythme la france
soutient à bras le corps les régimes
autocratiques d'afrique a tant dit
maintenir ses intérêts politiques dans
les colonies actuelle de la france ces
répressions provocation à la violence
quand l'état envers karine 3000
militaires forte alors que les canal
sont en deuil depuis la recrudescence du
conte vide et qu'ils ont dû leur droit
de bafouer par un référendum
d'autodétermination qui s'est fait sans
eux 56 % d'abstention et mat on ose
reconnaître les résultats
la françafrique c'est aussi l'ingérence
économie de la france dans ses anciennes
colonies et public aux dépens plan au
développement foncez pas adepte c'est
l'état français qui a la main sur le
portefeuille et leur sont des africains
la france et les dirigeants corrompus
s'enrichit pendant que les populations
africaines tente de garder la tête hors
de l'eau au côté de l'état les
multinationales françaises total le
groupe bolloré et j'en passe ce même
bolloré qui a la main ce qui a la
mainmise sur les médias français des
médias coupables de stigmatiser toujours
plus les populations afro descendantes
et immigrés et qui contribue à la montée
de la haine raciale le chômage et la
pauvreté tous les africains venir
s'installer en france et en europe à la
recherche d'amélioration de leurs
conditions de vie mais leur liberté
circulation est entravée par les lans
françaises et européennes sur ceux des
années sur six lorsqu'il s'agit des
africains arrivés sur le territoire
français on est ici on est discriminé
tig baptisé est victime de violences
policières de fait des décennies les
immigrés et leurs descendants subissent
en france des discriminations à l'emploi
au logement et des contrôles au faciès à
l'image des terres de montpellier venu
de paris pour manifester contre le
sommet afrique france et interpellés à
leur descente de train à l'image des
jeunes habitant les quartiers populaires
constamment harcelé abuser par la police
nous dénonçons ce système qui maintient
les africains les immigrés et leurs
descendants en bas de l'échelle sociale
assure vie nous appelons les
organisations de la solidarité
internationale à rejoindre la campagne
anti racisme solidarité nous ne pouvons
dénoncer les a vus que la plante comme
et en afrique sans dénoncer les abus que
la france comme est ici à l'encontre des
immigrés et de leurs descendants
la solidarité doit s'y prendre forme
dans notre lutte contre le racisme
merci rover
[Applaudissements]
vingt huit super
pouvait
avancer à souligner leurs rangs se veut
s'il vous plaît
avant mon vaisseau de plus en plus fort
sur les haies l'hexagone et nous sommes
de plus en plus nombreux en être
conscient
l'action anti raciste commune ça pose
mais pèsera qu'à condition que nous
ayons toutes et tous la conscience la
machine de guerre qui se déploieront
déploie aujourd'hui en cohérence avec
des préjugés profondément ancrées parce
que nos combattu
abondamment répandu
parce que seriné podor quatre siècles d
esclavage et un siècle et demi de
colonisation
citera crime policiers par an en moyenne
et ont lieu dans nos quartiers
populaires c'est la continuité de cette
histoire qui porte un nom la gestion
coloniale des quartiers populaires
le problème de ce pays c'est cette
histoire trop l'onion non réglés et le
racisme structurel
développé par les gouvernements
successifs à sa tête
d'où l'apparition régulière des monstres
qu'il s'appelle pétain le pen vous et
nous ils remettent en question l'idée
même des qualités et veulent procéder à
un véritable étoile agetic ojectif de la
propagation de l'infection ou ce titre
en remplacement
et chamond phobies et la négrophobie
nous allons passer et sont bien ancrées
dans notre présent car elles ont une
fonction politique précise
elle permet de désigner mais monsieur
noir les migrants les noix les règles
comme boucs émissaires responsables de
tous les maux outre lesquels toutes les
discriminations deviennent possibles et
donc acceptable
loin d'exception contre les séparatistes
agressions physiques et verbales contre
les musulmans femmes voilées notamment
fermeture de leurs lieux de culte
menaces de mort et d'expulsion des imams
dissolutions d'associations
antiracistes comme le s'essayait où la
crise
nous re disais et si
résistance et solidarité
elles permettent aussi de justifier
l'apprenti la fermeture des frontières
et donc de mort de dizaines de milliers
d'enfants de femmes et d'hommes rhône
méditerranée oui elle est un moyen et
nous réduisons face à l'horreur pas
salinesi à l'inacceptable
nous disons résistance des solidarités
[Applaudissements]
elle permet de justifier les guerres
impérialistes la présence française en
afrique
d'imposer par la force au peuple kanak
un référendum d'autodétermination
pipés d'avancé
de réprimer un coup de jijel le
mouvement social au delà nous et nous
disons aussi
résister
solidarité
[Applaudissements]
dans les quartiers populaires nous
subissons tout et tous les
discriminations à l'emploi au logement
de l'éducation
face à la justice
aujourd'hui la drum pauvreté frappe
beaucoup d'entre nous la répression et
le harcèlement policier que nous
subissons depuis des décennies ont servi
de laboratoire à se mener contre tout le
mouvement social celui des 10 les jeunes
notamment
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui pour faire
rentrer ces réalités à visibiliser
il est un de tous merci de mettre tous
ces problèmes sur la table pour créer un
véritable trop anti raciste mais
celui-ci ne sera possible que si les
organisations de la gauche sociale et
politique
clarifient leur position
sur l'islamophobie et sur le racisme
d'état
tout cela pose un contexte politique
aussi dramatique
cette coach était resté plus banalement
muet face à la loi dite contre les
séparatistes
l'espoir est elle restée globalement nul
face à la dissolution tu s'essayait ou
de la crise
[Musique]
pourquoi le mouvement anti-impérialiste
est il si insignifiant en france et
s'ils peuvent ou pas soutenu par la
gauche
ce métis profite à la fois un ultra père
à
l'ultralibéralisme d'un matheron et aux
extrêmes droites sam ouverte si raciste
conséquent ils s'imposeront par le
racisme le fascisme pour toutes et tous
mais attention quelle somme la sangle la
récolte ne tue pas d'heure
merci merci beaucoup
les camarades de la jeune garde
bonjour bonjour à tous je m'appelle tony
je suis membre de la jeune garde alors
déjà c'est très important pour nous
d'être ici aujourd'hui pour apporter
notre soutien à tous les exilés et c'est
aussi très important qu'on soit au jour
ici aujourd'hui pour montrer une énorme
solidarité anti fasciste à l'heure où
les idées racistes les idées d'extrême
droite sont de plus en plus banalisée on
peut voir que des gens comme zemmour
comme marine le pen peuvent se présenter
à l'élection présidentielle
alors qu'ils ont un discours
alors qu'ils ont un discours clairement
raciste c'est notre oeuvre
l'extrême droite est de plus en plus
présente et aller de plus en plus
violente
leur écrin il faut qu'on s'organise
quand on voit les médias a donné la
parole à des gens qui ont des discours
racistes en permanence qui déversent
leur haine quelqu'un comme seymour qui
qualifie les mineurs isolés d'un violeur
deux voleurs quelqu'un comme je suis
bien ou douze membres du rassemblement
national qui dit carrément qu'il faut
laisser les exilés à la frontière et les
laisser mourir de froid comment est ce
qu'on peut dire de telles choses
illégales sur des chaînes de grandes
hôtel
faut pas oublier la violence que
subissent les éxilés en arrivant sur le
sol français faut pas l'oublier des
milices d'extrême droite des néonazis
qui sont capables d'attaquer
physiquement violemment en plein meeting
des militants antiracistes pacifiste on
l'a vu au meeting de zemmour des milices
d'extrême droite comme génération
identitaire dissous il ya maintenant un
an qu'ils menaient de véritables
missions à la frontière pour faire la
chasse aux exilés pour faire la chasse
aux migrants
faut pas oublier aussi la violence de
l'état français qui laisse des centaines
et des centaines de personnes à la rue
sans eau sans électricité sans
nourriture
la violence de l'état français qui
refusent de venir en aide à calais à des
hommes des femmes et des enfants qui
prennent le risque de traverser la
manche au péril de leur vie
l'impérialisme occidental est
responsable de tout ça l'état français
est responsable de tout ça
alors face à ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait
comment on s'organise on crée à front
large et l'unitaire rassemblant les
maximum de personnes des militants des
non militants déjà du papier des gens
sans papiers
tout notre temps social des associations
des collectifs pour faire face à ces
groupes racistes pour faire face à ces
partis d'extrême droite
qui dénigrent tout ce qu'on représente
pour faire face à ces gens qui nous
attaque qui attaque tout ce qui
représente pas leur idéal fascisme à la
jeune garde aujourd'hui on est fier et
on est honorée d'être à vos côtés et on
le répète l'anti fascisme et la sphère
de toutes et tous tout le monde peut se
tire anti fasciste et tout le monde doit
s'approprier ce combat y a que comme ça
qu'on y arrivera et qu'on fera reculer
ces sites est un raciste merci à tout le
monde
si l'ogm à 6
non je sais ça fait poliment
que sa
solidarité
aux minorités rêve entre rafael
folie d'arrivée avec les sans-papiers
solidarité contre rachid
solidarité entre les fascistes s'il vous
plaît libérez le boléro s'il vous plaît
il me rappelle à mamirolle avant les
redevances s'il vous plaît à dire
autrement s'il vous plaît d'imagés plus
mario 20
ans dans les rucks et mouvements
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît à ma maison
ces mots pleins
s'il vous plaît
à
d
[Musique]
oh
le oh
[Musique]
on
ouais
[Musique]
m
je
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
et
oui
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oubli
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les jours
[Musique]
avec le long du doubs
bienvenue
au
centre de rétention si sa maman toute
l'europe raymond il ya des enfants qui
avaient mobilisé
à l'état
areva
[Musique]
m
ouais
[Musique]
leur retour
il
déjà là
oui
[Musique]
dieu
ou
pas
[Musique]
ct
m
nous sommes moins de deux heures
[Musique]
enfin
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
non
ça va
m
[Musique]
on
m
je me sens pas
elle
[Musique]
à
toujours pas
je
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
il
oui tout
non
[Musique]
du
premier
[Musique]
g
la queue
tél
[Musique]
m
photo g
bien
attention
j'en avais
culture
banco
on peut tuer
bien
[Musique]
non
certes pas inquiet
à
m
[Musique]
à
beaucoup
[Musique]
m
tant mieux
oh
mais
je n'irai pas
[Musique]
et
non
m
la vie
[Musique]
n'a pas
l'intention est beaucoup
trop
nous étions de papier
[Musique]
nous avons
nous
nous étions des enfants
[Musique]
nous étions
nous était
[Musique]
illégale m
la somme
n'était pas là
[Musique]
nous avons livré la france
on va les pousser
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
picot
[Musique]
oui
mais
[Musique]
oui
allez
[Musique]
oh
même avant d'errance de vente
offrant des rendements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
mirage 2000
je me demande s'il vous plaît
mais c'est malheureux
[Musique]
oui
pour
mais
[Musique]
m
vraiment
comment
[Musique]
devancé
ce
roman s'il vous plaît à suivre la
demande
s'il vous plaît je
vais venir on avance plus il vous plait
les rendements s'il vous plaît
pas non plus un autre
[Musique]
alors s'il vous plaît
à
on
non
[Musique]
on
c'est m
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
je veux
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
oui
là
à
[Musique]
paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ag as
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
ce soir
ja
[Applaudissements]
à
allez
[Applaudissements]
avec les aborder
salut
allez
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas sûr
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
oh
oui
non
oh
en mairie
[Musique]
oh
salez
avec
ça
[Musique]
on
oh
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il pose
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
so so solidarité
avec les sans-papiers
[Musique]
so
solidarité
avec les sans-papiers
[Musique]
cependant les
changer
solidarité avec les sans-papiers
les
valorisations
égalisation
[Musique]
régularisation
c'est pas les amandiers de polémiquer
[Musique]
poulet sans papiers
sans papiers
[Musique]
pour les immigrés
vont changer
[Musique]
on ne peut pas
parler
[Musique]
tous les sans papiers s'est pas laissée
par les militaires
[Musique]
régularisation de tous les sans voix ce
palace un banquier en agilité cette
harmonie il faut changer et qu'un
manteau pour la
régularisation de tous les sans papiers
le chi l'ha risation tourné semblait
céphalées sur vos pieds par les
macrophages
et écope à coeur pour nommer
régularisation de tous les sans-papiers
régularisation des sans-papiers
régularisation des sans papiers
l'égalisation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
la limite est
franchie
[Musique]
il faut changer
francs
régularisation enfin qu'il est
[Applaudissements]
le sans-papiers
[Musique]
ça
non non
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
vous
là
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
à voir
[Musique]
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aulas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
les sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les villas
tous les légumes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
changer
m
[Musique]
pour
non non
[Musique]
non
ouais
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien m
tout y est
[Musique]
mon
genou
à voir
[Musique]
sur nos réseaux sociaux rien en garde à
vue vendredi soir et
[Musique]
bien le voir
je ne vois
pas
[Musique]
nous
réclamons arrive au
[Musique]
bon moment
non
[Musique]
en apprenant
on est tout seul
par passion
pour désinfection par la fusion
attention
ce soir
[Musique]
ces
migrants pied arrêté le retard sur mu et
le sans papiers à des solutions
nouvelles radios centre de
tokyo avait terminé
avec attention
[Musique]
arrêtez les lois disent oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
m
[Musique]
toi
pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu
[Musique]
oh
3 à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tha
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
côté jour toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah bon
je
oh
[Musique]
pour
elle
[Musique]
oui
il
[Musique]
côté bon
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reportage
et
[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
pour
coc
on
[Musique]
moi je n'ai pas
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention
[Musique]
on
bon
non
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un grosse bâtisse yens ouais
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
je n'ai plus de changer
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
non
à tomber
[Musique]
beaucoup
ouais
voyage pour rien
[Musique]
téléphone
koné d'avoir trois ans
pour là je me sens donc
il est mieux là bas
[Musique]
je le don
ça bouge plus
normalement il semble qu'ils avaient un
point où là bas mais ne tape au loin
quand même
vous
de l'autre
[Musique]
celle là je commence
soc mais quoi
moi je suis
non vers le sud génère dans le bain
quand ils ont ce qu'ils ont tous quelque
chose en place ce qu'on appelle un
habitant
cité les six essais laissant paraître
une fois qu'il sent qu'ils sont mal de
vent encore
possible et sans le soutien du patron de
conti
nationale
ont une amitié ce même ancrage
bonsoir tout le monde
je me présente en demande couler
j manque de collectif sans papiers de
montreuil et de la marche de solidarité
j'interviens aux orties pour la marche
de solidarité
j'ai mûri tous les plateaux télé j'ai
des racistes qui aurait paralysé
des millions de gens de votre mari
l'open c'est les politiques migratoires
qui rime avec la même
valérie pécresse déclare candidat c'est
la promesse d'un missile puissamment et
les lois scélérates
parce qu'on répond aux aspirations
indique colonialiste et m'ont demandé au
japon de prendre à 15,1 des exactions et
pénaliste
ces poussées raison à la fin de la
marche de solidarité et le prix de 2
euros comme il faut nous on nous ment
costumes massivement aux audi emprunt de
son nez le début de l'année sports et de
la vie à travers la campagne anti
raciste de solidarité
amadou gai et en plus mr il s'appelle
dignité aux pumas franck ce gamin à
rêver alors qu'ils se rendaient à une
manifestation pacifique à montpellier
pour les rangs du sommet france-afrique
allonger cette manifestation a été
autorisée par la préfecture de paris
est acceptée et informer les autorités à
montpellier
notre grande surprise à l'arrivée de la
gare
on a trouvé une dizaine de policiers de
vanille
comme quoi disent en effet une photo
tandis que nous sommes dans un pays où
la manifestation
est un droit
parmi les sept camarades se sont trouvés
dans les centres et
les synchros qui sévit infligé au
capitaine
rennais
bien sûr
beaucoup de français connaissent les
auditeurs
mais majorité ne connaissent pas bien je
vais vous expliquer cette fois quelqu'un
dire car c'est un système politique et
j'ai non seulement
les sans papiers ce truc dans la
précarité mais pour les mettre dans les
précarités argent
quand j'allais être
différé c'est la presse il a de temps en
temps tu peux pas être les réaliser
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il faut dix
minutes
julien deux domaines
aussi - ou le coup vu beaucoup de
camarades vont se dire tu es d'ici six
mois ces systèmes moi ça va quoi s'est
passé alors
il faudrait demander aux eyzies non
seulement rentrer dans son pays
d'origine
il faut aller à la 11ème ou en face à
des défenses d'un bouquet tourisme aussi
aller pourrait arriver bouder les délais
des autorités libyennes commencent
ça c'était le cas de bien
nous nous sommes développés mais rené
paquet des sans papiers nous sommes
aussi de méritas
militants qui partaient tous m'ont payé
pour montrer sa vie militante il
y avait quoi les sommets france afrique
nous aussi on a voulu briser non tu
prends du sommet on effraie anglais
faire pacifiquement mais malheureusement
c'est cette caméra qui ont pris une
belle carrière ces séminaires à tous ces
personnes là on vient de commencer une
campagne conséquent vol on devrait de
mêler deux mois et des semaines ça va
pas s'arrêter à cette montre
que le groupe smr qui s'appelle un
granité ses moeurs comme c'est qu'avant
la parité je reviens du bâtiment mon
levier à rien s'il reste un pied
d'égalité les recevoir
si on accepte
soit il est exploité et a sonné
call me poupée est étouffée il s'appelle
limité et tout mais quand vous êtes un
an et demi et me donne mon âme et lidl
la nicotine peut s'imaginer
centaine
d'enfants de six ans
motif les produits à cause des bruits
il s'appelle solidarité
nous les volumes sans papiers
nous allions à % des 8
nous demandons à tous les partis
syndicats associations
de nous résume bd cette cavale pour la
solidarité et les radis en tout l'on dit
volontiers
si vous
[Musique]
savez
au bout du bout
clientèle souvent de faire des reproches
moi intime où les jets de réponse
dans les conjuguer nos livres sont
divisés de me renier leur ai dit
l'arrêt projet on est impuissants ont
demandé à tout le monde de sortir la
question
devant nous et c'est déjà une bonne
prestation à la cour
d'une maison dans un pays aujourd'hui
il faut mêler ou s'amuser avec ses
paysages à cette fois pendant la télé
essayent de semer la haine entre la
population
les français
nous les appliquer en somme on peut
consulter cette traversée
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
il m'apparaît afat etienne
soeur de lamine dieng tué par la police
montée comité vérité et justice pour la
ville et des réseaux trade du réseau de
traite mérité justice
[Musique]
on sorte noir je m'appelle pas tous
viennent une des soeurs de lamine dieng
du comité vérité je suis pour la médiane
du collectif vie volée et du réseau
d'entr'aide vérité justice où
la ligne a été tué le 17 juin 2007 par
clé d'étranglement et placage moral il
n'avait que 25 ans il a fallu que la
paille ou iv soutien se battent du rhin
présents pour faire reconnaître le
meurtre de la mine déclenchée en juin
2020 que la cour européenne a rendu sa
décision et que les phares français a
reconnu sa responsabilité dans le
meurtre de la mine
aujourd'hui
un réseau était constitué en fin de
manche les dégoûter le réseau
n'entraînent vérité justice et un
ensemble de bonnes équipes et là bas de
familles de victimes pied par la police
la gendarmerie la prison des personnes
mutilées et blessés par les forces de
l'ordre des familles qui ont perdu un
proche les habits paris sans forcer des
collectifs en terrasse et 11 du gâchis
et contre les violations des droits
humains en mars dernier le réseau
n'entraînent vérité justice appelée avec
nos paroles de tout faire de la marche
de solidarité et d'autres collectifs à
la dixième année de marche contre la
piraterie scénique de violences
policières pénitentiaire et judiciaire
dans de nombreuses villes
voyons voir ensemble pour une nouvelle
édition en mars 2022 car le danger ne
serait d'une part et l'extrême droite ni
à des individus politique mal
intentionnés raciste sexiste homophobe
des lots favre c'est tout un système qui
nous oppresse et qui nous divise en
france les crimes racistes et les
violations des droits humains du fait
d'une discrimination raciale ont été
instituées alizés 1 pour y soigner des
cargos avec le code noir 2014 puis avec
par le code de l'indigénat
sur la république l'état français dans
la continuité de ces violences de crimes
exerçaient ce depuis très longtemps à
l'encontre les compilations paul minn et
en outre mer qu'en métropole
depuis cette époque
la répression violente noir mortelle de
personnes baptisées me consulte et
s'étend désormais aux poupées mais ceux
qui contestent la politique
gouvernementale
le constat que ces comportements et
d'illégitime des agences n'a qu'à monter
comme hervé du
parti sont
couverts par l état autoritaire sans
retenue nous sommes confrontés un piste
elle cultive et aux riches et le racisme
le mensonge le fort des usages de faux
en écriture publique et leur fabrique du
non-lieu
illégitime le déni de justice les
violences et les crimes continuent en
toute impunité
poursuivant de politique facile anti
migratoire est respectée du maintien de
l'ordre en arguant des lois liberticides
des contrôles au faciès des contrôles
aux frontières et en étendant le permis
de tuer
pourrait y faire cela nous arpentons
dans son soutien à chaque fois que cela
est nécessaire pour demander vérité
justice et réparation dans un intérêt
commun nous malgré son tout votre
soutien au collectif de sans-papiers aux
personnes exilées migros aux victimes
aux familles des disparus aux familles
endeuillées comble était inutile et une
grande pensée
ce 18e de ce 18 décembre aux familles en
et qui organise ces commémorations et
tournoi de foot en hommage à leurs
proches disparus seule celle de matisse
tête et lobe 18 est grand temps tu est
rappelé par un ter le 15 décembre
2010 est en fuyant la police un lead
d'olivier gomez 28 ans j'ai partir de
police le 17 octobre 2020 à poissy
d'ibrahima à 22 ans tué par des
policiers qui ont barré volontairement
la route à villiers le bel les
sprinteurs tordre 2019 de ziani 20 ans
mortellement blessé le 14 chanteurs 2000
le 14 avril 2021 parce qu'ils étaient
pris en charge de manière très
dangereuse par une voiture de la bac est
mort des suites de cette blessure le 3
juin 2020 2021 pardon nous pensons
également à babacar gaye tué par la bac
en décembre 2015 alors liste alors que
cela fait de moins d'un an qu'il est
comme vous avez rejoint casseurs awa
guèye à rennes dans un parcours
difficile du sénégal à rennes en passant
par le maroc et l'espagne depuis sa
soeur awa mais le combat est à porte à
porte et détermination auprès des
familles de victimes des personnes
blessé des personnes exilées son papier
pour contrer la mémoire de son frère
dans cette lutte commune renault dans
les violents racistes départ
nous exprimons et appelons à la
solidarité avec les sept personnes sans
papiers est appelée à montpellier pour
avoir voulu démonter la françafrique et
on enlève l'or 2021 nous rendons aussi
hommage à paris pétard du collectif des
sans-papiers de montreuil mois on sera
chantier le 18 avril 2021 non non non je
peux ainsi qu'un alors le temps nous
laissons papier décime
exploité par le patronat et le système
capitaliste
nous rendons hommage aux sans papiers
des ces erreurs ont le centre de
rétention administrative et aux visées
de milliers de personnes mortes noyées
en tentant de traverser la manche où
l'américain lui les cavaliers au nom du
nous allons également y penser
de force et de courage face à la justice
pour tous les bateaux leur expliquer
leur qu'elle n'avait alors qu'elles
avaient construit leur vie en france
mais condamnée
à travers le réseau n'entraînent vérité
je suis nous combattons toutefois jean
ping aux violations de droits humains
comme le racisme ni l'impunité ou la
violence routière et excuses à tous et
présence des violences de corps de
l'homme
nous exigeons le respect de la liberté
pour toutes et tous
avec un même traitement juridique et
sociale une justice équitable que nos
fondamentaux et par nos dirigeants
contre le virus d'humain
mettre fin au contrôle d'identité
permanent et mettre en place leur écoute
et qui remplissent les agents à
justifier sous contrôle de ce fait le
délit d'outragé et rébellion
pour en finir avec les procédures
abusives du harcèlement quotidien
1,15 vers le rhin seulement répressive
judiciaires contre les manifestants
abroger l'article permis d'y tuer avant
l'article
434-1
intervenir les techniques des souffrants
et les tremblements bagages entre hal et
pillages intervient les armes placé
armes de guerre et bd et grenade et le
pistolet électrique
elle a violé
et les courses-poursuites
tube révèle usages les hématies b et des
nappes en jean lob clamé les quartiers
du devant et disciplinaires découdre les
études de maths encagoulés
contre la qulité le déni de justice on
demande la création d'un organe
indépendant pour enquêter sur les
plaintes contre les forces de l'ordre et
les surveillants pénitentiaires et peut
rien lente et l'indépendance des
artistes scientifiques nécessaires
dépaysé systématiquement l'instruction
des plaintes contre lui par dollars et
les surveillants pénitentiaires mettre
en place une habitant cytologique
systématique pour les victimes et leurs
proches et la gratuité des soins
nécessaires
garantir la prise en charge complète par
la sécurité sociale et les mutuelles des
soins et traitements médicaux
nécessaires
consécutifs à des joueurs des far
garantir l'audition par le magistrat
tout un secteur de moins identifiés
l'euro vers une copie de leur position
et le revenu messieurs votre action
garantir l'accès de tous les ajustements
aux jeux et vidéos disponibles
ont cadré et un gage de stabilité
médecins venant à les procédures
judiciaires contre lui tu es de
dénigrement dénigrement et les violences
y être sans papiers
la liberté de circulation et
d'installation
la régularisation
l'abolition des mesures administratives
d'internement et d'expulsion notamment à
travers des élus udb pure tm pardon et
des cuillères irt m la procession
automatique dès leur arrivée des jeunes
étrangers
isolés la fermeture des centres de
rétention
la l'égalité des droits pour tous dans
tous les domaines le droit de vote des
étrangers et enfin nous buzon la
suspension immédiate des agents mis en
cause pour violences pour homicide et
leur radiation définitive la suspension
immédiate des agents ayant comme il est
bon ou commis des actes racistes et
l'homme radiation définitive
l'abrogation de tous à liberty tiff
sécuritaire rassis effectifs qui ont
justifié et je dirais encore
l'augmentation des moyens des forces de
l'ordre de torken pénitentiaire en les
armant davantage en le prévu les gens
davantage quand une population de plus
en plus criminalisés contrôler fichiers
opprimés blessés mutilés et tués
sokratis et aux violences policières
carcéral et judiciaire
top à l'impunité allons l humilité
accordée aux agents assermentés et
ejustice les réparations pour toutes les
victimes disent y ait là bas denses et
un dojo for courage et dignité aux
familles endeuillées aux blessés et aux
mutilés merci à vous
au fait à jean
paul dispard mais
[Applaudissements]
on a bien gêné pour le front contre les
jeunes on souffle pour l'égalité
pour ça
mon sac a déjà jeté le remercie tous les
collectifs de sans papiers
a pas
permis de
de renforcer le but de devenir pour des
coachs commune ce soit pour les
violences policières contre
l'islamophobie contre tous les racismes
contre l'exclusion d'une partie de la
population
donc noces est venu avec le fond contre
l'islamophobie pour dire stop stop à
l'islamophobie d'état stop au racisme
d'état pointe du doigt que ça soit les
immigrés les sans papiers les musulmans
et notamment vers les électorale on a
tant parlé de nous tout le temps mais on
nous entendons nous donne pas la parole
de qu'on parle pour nous on part de nous
pourra s'en trouve le même pas par nous
et c'est pas nous qui va ou ses 100 dans
tout le temps donc nous rend les vrais
joindre la parole pour dénoncer tout ce
qui ne va pas ruiner
on cache les problèmes de la forte
puisqu'elle et les problèmes sociaux
égaux en ce moment la précarité le show
faible
les sans-papiers par les migrants parler
les musulmans et nous ont dit stop on
dit stop à tout ça voilà en tout cas je
remercie et à mesure que nous ne soit
commune parce que cette chanson qu'on va
changer des choses c'est nous l'apprend
c'est nous
[Applaudissements]
je donne la parole un vrai sens pour
attac au nom de toutes les associations
je rappelle clé vous pouvez signer
individuellement j'ai signé aussi
les rideaux les locaux du quartier
célèbre s'appelait dit que le sport
j'appelais des lieux culturels ils sont
beaux sites du monde s'y met dans cette
campagne antiraciste solidarité ouest
d'ataq nationale d'apprendre à pareil
pour toutes les associations
[Musique]
merci encore à tous points merci
beaucoup à tous et à toutes les parties
pour la manif aujourd'hui c'est très
important pour nous aussi d'être là
aujourd'hui ne serait pas à trio riz car
bon nombre d'associations nation entière
à 6 mais on est au premier rang porte
son str unir toutes les luttes qui vient
d'être évoqué la question des sans
papiers la question bien sûr des
violences policières de l'islamophobie
mais au delà la question des
discriminations dans le monde du travail
à l'université dans les quartiers c'est
pour ça qu'on doit construire
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a fait une
magnifique manille
rit aussi dans alice très nombreuses
villes en france et le premier devoir
d'une grotte pour femmes qui va se
dynamiser à partir de 2001 2002 ça doit
être l'année de marine le pen ou d'eric
zemmour ça doit pas être l'année des
poursuites des politiques xénophobes ça
doit être l'année de la solidarité de la
dignité notre pays safed solidarité
c'est ce qu'on veut dire qu'on va
conduire à dire dans les quartiers dans
les villages dans les lieux de travail
et d'étude on va que je continue tous
ensemble on se retrouve très bientôt
dans la rue et des comptes courants pour
organiser les mérites yatim contre le
racisme est beau est limité merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
militaires stationnés question des guns
roses pâles les animaux mais aussi parce
qu'en ce moment mais dès ce week-end
même ne sans papiers qui se fait qu'ils
emmenaient récente gagner il faut
absolument aller soutenir wall pour
finir ici
[Musique]
à
cela il invitera chefs ont alors bonjour
tout le monde d'abord la fédération s'il
fait c'est et je crois que nous on a
senti qu'un solidaire on voulait saluer
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont
manifesté aujourd'hui parce que la
meilleure réponse à l'ambiance
complètement pourri qu'on a en ce moment
elle est dans la rue pour laver en
réponse au racisme d'état elle est dans
la rue et pour parler de racisme d'état
et 109 est de multiples manières parler
des discriminations
l'accès au logement à l'emploi parler
que l'once policière par l'empilement
des lois racistes qui tombe depuis des
années et par l'exploitation évidemment
les travailleurs et travailleuses sans
papiers et à ce racisme d'état
correspond un racisme institutionnel
d'entreprises et de ce point de vue là
la poste qui est plus gros employeur en
france après l'état et appelle exemple
que patrons voyous qui exploite est
surexploité travailleurs sans papiers
les deux points de vue là évidemment la
lune et camarades chronos étaient payés
et non seulement exemplaires par le
courage la détermination tout dire a
indiqué cho réduit tout vous écrasez n'y
point c'est évidemment exemplaire et qui
a montré courageux mais c'est aussi très
important dans ce final à part que à la
tête du groupe la poste on a des patrons
qui dit la réalité d'un surexploitation
des sans-papiers et pourtant on est là à
quelques jours de noël
une période de fin d'année des millions
et des milliards de colis sont
distribués un peu partout dans le pays
alors nous présente ça comme la magie du
e-commerce on clique série v mais
derrière la magie du tonnerre qui génère
des profits gigantesques au plateau une
course de notre rythme via
l'exploitation et la surexploitation des
travailleurs sans papiers de travail
soutient dans la logistique et je tiens
juste à saluer mes collègues le canada
qui symbolise depuis plus d'un mois tous
sont à jour et nuit qui relève la tête
par un patronat extrêmement puissant et
qui sont un exemple pour l'entente des
costières des postures pays comme les
travailleurs sans papiers sont deux
points vu avec ça pour l'enfant du monde
du travail terme il a juste à 10 ans
sait qu'il ya des échanges de
mobilisation à l'appoint murales datant
du mois de janvier et pour nous c'est
géant elles sont totalement liés aux
mobilisations du monde ravages du
travail dans son ensemble est évidemment
que ces franges les plus précarisés les
plus exploités qui vivent dans les
conditions les plus difficiles mais qui
lui hier des de manière la plus
déterminée et on en est convaincu ces
travailleurs dits a été colonisé c'est
travailleurs aujourd'hui ils sont
exploités et de montants de ces
travailleurs seront régularisés
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde se nomme elle agit
donc mam de quel type de travail sans
papiers de vitry et en même temps que
des listes à
québec général pour résumer vous parle
et qui sont
prêts
mais il m'a tout d'abord pour saluer
assez à celle qui organise cette durée
et qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce pays
c'est dommage car quand ils ont besoin
de nous vivons comme chez ses
collègues dans le bye bye ont rejoint
des mèches blanches et des sans papiers
si c'est dans la restauration nous
approchons de vire ou six ans pour dire
si c'est en les exposant les colis qui
tenait devant aller voir par tous et les
sans papiers qui sauvent et là et là on
dit que ça suffit les emplois qu'elles
nous ont dit que il faut concevoir si on
ne se bat pas on va pas avoir de toit et
là on a obliqué fois la première place
des pilotes au mythe on
donc c'est arrivé si c'est les flammes
un sans papiers qui sont à nos patois et
là je crois ce même si le maire de la
ville de genève il est quand même qui
est un soutien assez
travaillé sans papiers vous savez tous
le parti va alors tout s'est tu ne t'es
pied dans le bâtiment à le voir courir
d'autres là ils ont clamé un communiqué
on parlera samedi chose le sait caresser
les soucis de santé
mais ça reste mon cheminement fin 2009
car les maintenant elle a
décidé de faire c'est à 2,91
à
l'ennemi numéro un donc c'est plus dans
l'es3 puis qu'il ya plus de 70 ans ont
passé et la dcri de 15 mois
nous sommes encore mais on
était minuit sur le plus régulier en or
parce qu'après je vous saisit
les personnes qui étaient dedans des
sans papiers des humains non ne prenons
pas ne vous n'avez pas le droit de
manger j'avais su ce
que de nous pouvait rentrer dedans si ce
n'est pas durable et deux cartes avec
une tournée en chemin nous apprendra
plus beaux nos pensées de tous - dedans
est là avec core hors
du temps d'y arriver à nous sortir de là
et de piqué et nous sommes solidaires
devant l'entrepôt était plus lente nous
sommes la racheta présent on danse ou de
voir
le piquet de grève est à moi ça mais ça
date d'à nos camarades ont occupé sans
vie relate aussi au dessus ils ont pris
connaissance
lors des recherches originales de la
poste 104 le constat formule ils ont vu
qu'on ya des sans papiers qui sont à la
lutte dans la transe qui sont licenciés
tout sans papiers
de la nouvelle travée organisée la
veille cela dit ce qu'elle disait 'le
2009 mercredi à beni karina
régularisation 2006 no et 47 foot hier
ils ont dit que ça commençait le parti
ils ont licencié les bras et de laquelle
radicaux
libres que le couple ait lieu à prendre
avec les personnes qui travaillent dans
les ports audio aac arno cost est les 83
qui a été révisé depuis là c'est une vie
communautaire et des télés sitôt je dis
à tout le moins sur toi sa première qui
se dit pour consoler si sorcier ont
scellé par on va nous piétiner seront
accomplis c'est pas d'élus
que nous allons gagner tous c'est pas de
livres que nous verrons est là nous on a
commencé on va aller on va voir lâcher
ses travers et on demande à tout le
moins un bon mois de remous cette année
dans ses récits
[Musique]
dans un contexte d'attaqués migros et
des musulmans
dans un contexte où le racisme
la tête des médias
aujourd'hui nous étions il avait plus de
50 rassemblements dans toute la france
pour lutter contre la cible pour la
solidarité en particulier auprès des
migrants qui sont les tiens sont les
premières victimes
passage vous organisés ils ont lutté
pour prendre un but comme on l'a dit
contre l'exploitation on voit bien
comment le monde du travail comment le
capitalisme utilise le racisme et
l'hydratation des plus précaires et en
particulier les plus précaires des plus
précaires qui sont des travailleurs sans
papiers pour s'enrichir pas à ça on
continue à mobiliser
la campagne ne fait que commencer
aujourd'hui ce 18 décembre nous étions
des miniers partout en france mais cette
campagne anti ration des sondes il
ajouté
j'ai travaillé sur les différents axes
de cette campagne n'a lui contre tous
les racismes la liberté de circuler de
manifester l'égalité les droits la
dignité et la solidarité en particulier
avec les migrants contre le fascisme
contre le colonialisme contre tous les
racismes l'injustice et les inégalités
il faut continuer à construire l'unité
la solidarité
merci
[Applaudissements]
non certainement cette année nous allons
enfin tranquille de plus en plus fort
merci à tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'actuel
donc là
je
merci
il ya une chaîne de sport qui a aussi un
volet verte comme ça aussi office et
des fois je te faut
on va la faire la différence
manufer et
[Musique]
non
le
monde